estábamos en el club
ah
reunimos a 7 personas borrachas
estoy borracha estoy borracha estoy muy
borracho ahora estoy borracha estoy
borracha estoy muy borracho uno de ellos
está sobrio y si el grupo descubre
quiénes se dividirán el premio en
efectivo
el impostor sobrevive empecé a llevar a
todo el premio quién es el impostor
[Música]
en salud
debemos brindar por capital capital sin
capital hay champagne saltando por aquí
y tú y yo seremos dice tu nombre tu
nombre luís amigos hasta el final estoy
contigo hasta el fin creo que me vieron
todos antes
digamos los alientos no quiero leer a
nadie yo sí y estoy dispuesto a oler no
si estás tratando de leerme que es raro
no sé qué haces en tu tiempo libre pero
no voy a leer a nadie es decir que puedo
leer tu aliento bien adelante
y eso es realmente muy bien
eso
es difícil
porque nos dirige
dirige a los demás nos pregunta que me
vieron antes de esto vamos iremos en
orden si el bordear tome dos mimosas y
media y luego tome cuatro tragos y
después bebe un poco de mi mango de
tequila
hoy irlandesa perras tomé una botella
decir ok soy chica fresa era una edición
especial de granada
media botella fue el supermercado justo
antes de
la mitad de una botella también soy
representante de capital conocen esa
zona
mejor soda con alcohol del mundo es no
es un anuncio ahora mismo
y dinos solo tome una capital
se le seguía promocionando su marca su
marca de alcohol o marca de bebida
porque es literalmente la mejor ciudad
del mundo es mejor que white lo mejor
que cualquier otra cosa mi prima me
consiguió media botella de tequila de
dónde eres
londres
tienen asientos geniales puedes imitar
el acento estadounidense muy
discretamente podría ser un hitler
británico sabe podría ser más
definitivamente me viste se nota verdad
ustedes son buenos amigos
[Música]
retrocedan no quiero que nadie se enoje
conmigo
está bien así bien este es mi voto este
es mi voto no confío en él así que o si
estaba seguro de que era el británico
sólo porque no confío en los no
estadounidenses
no es que sea por eso sino porque no es
estadounidense
en serio los cientos de los monos puedo
lo siento
miren hasta el 30 con libre
estas pruebas
estamos en walmart pero probablemente
somos la mejor marca que existe si la
prueban dirán es cierto es la mejor
ciudad del mundo alguien se ve
trabalenguas que dice sal y sal de las
salinas
juguemos a girar la botella si nos
empiezan con el aire están sobrios pues
papá yo pienso que si te puedes besar
con cualquiera estando borracho
definitivamente lo estás porque si hay
algún titubeo puedes delatarte viento a
este nuevo girar lo debes tirarla
dios bien
[Aplausos]
ustedes deciden
hagámoslo para demostrar que estamos
borrachos qué me dices está bien listo
aquí vamos
bien en la mejilla en la mejilla
sólo un beso en la mejilla y si queremos
vamos
que puedo decir los está bien por mi
bien creo que bese un chico muy chulo
cual está bien nos besamos y demostramos
que todo está bien
no no escuchamos nada están hablando
muchos al mismo tiempo las personas a la
vez de lo contrario no podremos debemos
ser responsables
cuál es tu favorito
y
si
quieren ver la verdadera
de un ritmo de ritmo
[Aplausos]
quién fue la chica que hizo el split
kelly quien que eligen y eligen y que
elige lee que le lee adiós cuando hizo
el split dije ninguna persona sobria
haría eso aquí y ahora quiero verte
intentarlo
no es todo
eso fue todo todo esto
con algo de ritmo
mons
me odio y si sólo pudieran cortar esa
parte del cronk
me haría muy feliz
[Música]
[Aplausos]
debiste haber bailado cómo se llama el
britannia me puedes decir el británico
ok yo creo que es el parece el más
coherente el resto somos todo un
desastre
solo
eso
efe
[Música]
escribir es un poco difícil ahora además
soy estudiantes de psicología y pensé
que ella solo fingía estar borracha
[Música]
tenemos un empate
entre los tics y
yo quien votó por mí cada uno tendrá 20
segundos para convencer a los demás
comenzando por los tics está bien
honestamente no sé quién votó por mí
porque si estuviera sobria podría hacer
esto
bien creo que es el impostor creo que ya
todo se acabó el tiempo hey man es tu
turno bien miren tomé un par de tragos
de tequila antes de venir tomé un poco
más de tequila heller este borracho y
siento que alguien está tratando de
pasarme la pelota a mí los demás den un
paso hacia adelante para discutir a
quién les gustaría eliminar un
semicírculo bien está bien está bien
vamos a eliminar entonces tenemos ese
dinero vamos por el vino estamos de
acuerdo todos con las manos al medio
vamos eso es lo que quiero ver listas y
3 2 1
[Risas]
y
hablo en serio pensé que iba a ganar
dios mío male alves estaba glam borracha
que la gente pensó que estaba actuando
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue dentro y les gustaría
continuar el juego el chico del
patrocinio creo que ganamos yo igual yo
levanté mi mano y luego creo que la
persona a mi lado levantó la mano pero
nadie más lo hizo y todos dijeron oh sí
creo que lo sacamos pero no creo que lo
hiciéramos estamos votando ahora ya lo
hicimos esto es más si las luces se pone
en verde se encontraron el impostor y
ganan el dinero si se ponen rojas el
impostor todavía está dentro y pierden
hola
en el concierto
las luces se pusieron rojas era jay mal
sabía que no lo habíamos sacado sabía
que debíamos hacer otra ronda pero
confié demasiado en los demás del
impuesto revelarse en 3 2 y 1 ahora
me sorprendió estaba tan sorprendido era
la que menos imaginé la más lejana en mi
radar
y estaba muy sorprendida porque ella y
yo estuvimos hablando afuera antes si
ella estaba bebiendo de una botella así
que dije bien ella también está borracha
pero debe haber estado bebiendo agua o
fingiendo tomar un sorbo de 'la solía
ser una degeneración ahora no bebo sólo
es algo me divierto y actúa como una
borracha así lo hice solo se necesita
tiempo para amarte a ti mismo y ganar
esa confianza donde quiera que estés
parado a saber que no necesitas algo
para ser tú mismo y ser tan divertido
como quiera ser no puedes hacerlo sobria
y muy bien pueden salir todos excepto
que él y
lo siento los vamos
espero que cody reseña este vídeo
[Música]
y
se lo ganó